I'm so like relieved that I finally
made it.
It just feels so amazing you know to look around and say that I was a school like this.
Here we are
about to graduate with everything that I wanted to do here.
It was a long journey. I feel accomplished.
I am the first in my family to graduate.
It's going to be something very huge.
My toughest point was actually my first
quarter here.
So I didn't have very good study habits.
First year was kind of
hard figuring out how to study and stuff.
My first quarter here after I transferred.
First year was a very big struggle.
Things like kept rolling like and you had no
time to stop.
You get a midterm score back that's not what you wanted.
46%
I didn't do better on the final.
There was definitely times where I wanted to give up.
You push through for
sure.
I was just like staying up till 2:00 a.m. 3:00a.m. trying to finish.
I gave birth to my daughter and I just remember
thinking oh my god I don't think I'm
gonna be able to do this.
Hit the office hours. I was there like every office hour afterwards.
Going in to your T.A.
I had to make a lot of sacrifices and like
really learn how to manage my time.
I'll start by thanking my family of
course.
My parents.
Love to thank my parents.
Definitely my parents. I mean
that's pretty generic but they helped me
the most through my trek.
My husband so
much.
Having the same group of friends over the past four years.
Ellie Hernández from the Chicano Studies department.
My community college teachers.
They said like you'll thank me one day
for pushing you this hard.
I feel like the resources here at UCLA like the AAP it definitely helped me.
Dan Blumstein. It's just been nice to have his constant advice.
Life happens but
that doesn't mean you stop trying and stop
like doing what it is that you want.
Whenever people ask me what your school is it's nice to be able to say UCLA.